this might be a good place to kind of
compare influenza the flu and covid in
the context of the discussion we just
had which is um how deadly is covid so
you mentioned covet is a very particular
kind of steepness
uh more of the x-axis's age
so
in that context could you maybe compare
influenza and covid because a lot of
people
um outside the folks who suggest that
the the lizards who run the world have
completely fabricated invented covid
outside of those folks kind of the
natural process by which you dismiss the
threat of covet is say well it's just
like the flu the flu is a very serious
thing actually
um so in that comparison
what is kovitz then yeah the flu is a
very serious thing it kills you know 50
60 000 people a year something I found
that order depending on the the
particular strain that goes around uh
that's in the United States the primary
difference to me are the there's lots of
differences but one of the most Salient
differences is the age gradient and
mortality risk for the flu
so the flu is more deadly for two
children than covet is
there's no controversy about that
children thank God have much less severe
reactions to covid infection to than
that due to flu infections and rate of
fatalities fatality all of that I think
you mentioned
um I mean it's interesting to maybe also
Combat on I think in another
conversation you mentioned there's a
u-shape
to the
to the flu curve so meaning like there's
actually quite a large number of kids
that die from flu yeah I mean the 1918
flu the H1N1 flu that the Spanish Flu in
the U.S killed millions of of uh of
younger people
and um that is not the case with covid
more than
um I'm gonna get the number wrong but
something like 70 80 percent of the
deaths are people over the age of 60.
well we're talking about the fear the
whole time really
but my interaction with folks
now I want to have a family I want to
have kids but I don't have that real
first-hand experience but my interaction
with folks is at the core of fear that
folks had
is for their children
like
that
somehow you know I don't want to get
infected because of the kids like
because God forbid something happens to
the kids and I think that obviously that
makes a lot of sense this kind of the
kids come first no matter what that's
number one priority but in for this
particular virus that reasoning was
um not grounded in data it seems like or
that emotion and feeling yeah
at the same time this is way more deadly
than the flu just overall and especially
to older people yes right so the numbers
when when the story is all said and done
a coveted would take many more lives
yeah
so I mean point two is sounds like a
small number but it's not a small number
worldwide what do you think that number
will be by the you know that's not
that's not like me but would we cross I
think it's in the United States it's um
the way the desktop currently reports
like 800 000 something like that do you
think will cross a million seems likely
yeah do you think it's something that
might continue with different variants
what uh well I think um so we can talk
about the end state of covert the end
state of covet is it's here forever
um I think that there is good evidence
of immunity after infection
such that you're protected both against
re-infection and also against severe
disease upon reinfection
so the second time you get it it's not
true for everyone but for many people
the second time you get it will be
milder much milder than the first time
you get it with the long tail like uh
that lasts for a long time yeah so just
their studies that uh that follow course
people who are infected for a year
and the reinfection rate is something
like somewhere between 0.3 and one
percent yeah
um and like a pretty fantastic study of
Italy's found that there's ones in
Sweden I think there's a few studies
that found the similar similar things
um and the
reinfections tend to produce much milder
disease much less likely to end up in
the hospital much less likely to die
um so what the end state of covet is
it's circulating the population forever
and you get it multiple times
yeah and and then there's I think
studies and discussions like the the
best protection would be to get it and
then also to get vaccinated and then a
lot of people push back against that for
the obvious reasons from both sides
because somehow this the discourse has
become less scientific and more
political well I think you want to like
the first time you meet it is going to
be the most deadly for you and so the
first time you meet it it's just wise to
be vaccinated the vaccine reduces severe
disease